all right I want to make this video to
get out some thoughts I had on a recent
video mind getting rated M and I want to
talk about it because I don't see a lot
of other youtubers talk about what that
means to their channel and the
implications of that and I think they're
actually huge and so I think a lot more
of us should be talking about it so I
just wanted to give my experience and I
hope other youtubers do as well I also
think that I have a few things that
maybe some of you haven't heard of not
just the audience but creators as well
that I think could be useful so we're
gonna talk about a few things number one
how you can know you're rated M what it
meant for my channel and what I think it
means for your channel they just talked
about like sort of like the future of
YouTube and stuff this is really
informal I'm kind of doing this off the
cuff but it's really got me kind of
bothered so I just wanted to put down my
thoughts so let's start with how I knew
I was rated M because I think that's a
lot of something a lot of people don't
know first of all what is rated M it's a
it's a secret rating it's an invisible
rating both to the audience and to
creators this is not the same as an age
gating being rated M is an invisible tag
that you cannot see it does not affect
you don't have to click a sign-in button
in order to see the content but what it
does mean is that it is not going to be
shown to a lot of your audience and I'll
explain I'll unpack that a little bit
but first like how do we know it's real
so first of all on the ad side of
YouTube you can clearly see that
advertisers are selecting for these
ratings and then we've had these huge
expositions from people like CeeLo and
nerd nerd City I mean a lot of great
work has been done here so I don't want
to go through that but let's talk about
how I knew my video was rated M so so
first we have to talk about two things
the two most important things to views
on YouTube because I was really shocked
when my most recent video about vaping
versus smoking did so poorly because of
how well it was doing in the analytic
side so there are basically two ways of
knowing how well your videos gonna do
watch time how long people are watching
and then click-through rate
you know if they get shown your your
thumbnail like are they gonna click yes
or no binary so why was I surprised I
was surprised because my analytics were
great the video the video was doing like
super well it like as far as the
click-through rate it was 10 percent
which is that's a great click-through
rate for me for me especially like I
don't have great click-through rate
great click-through rate and then watch
time was incredible I think it's like 7
7 minutes and 55 seconds or something
right now but uh anything around the 7
to 8 minute mark is fantastic so I was
thinking oh this is gonna be huge video
this is gonna be an incredible video
it's that's better than most of my
analytics from my videos that have hit a
million views so this video if anything
is gonna hit you know 500,000 a million
views at least so you can understand why
I was confused when the video just died
at 140,000 views I'm you can see right
here it was a pretty average performing
video and then it just doesn't get
spread beyond the audience my
subscribers who are already watching it
it just doesn't get spread like most of
my videos and so eventually when my
average video average performing not
great but average video would do like
300,000 views in that time period this
one is at 141 thousand views and so yeah
that's when I knew something was up but
then I figured out what actually was
driving the thing to fail okay and it's
right here so if you look at if you look
at impressions by the way you can do
this at home so if you're wondering if
your video is rated M you can kind of
check this okay so you can see
impressions how they led to watch time
so you to recommended this but this is
what's important right here so you see
how it says like recommended on home
page versus recommended on watch page
okay so 50% of the views came from the
watch page what is that that's when
you're like watching YouTube it shows
you the new videos that you should watch
all right
so pay attention that 50% of my views
came from the watch page on that video
right and that's that's kind of a little
high for me I looked at my I looked at
my overall and overall I get my like
about 25 percent of my views from the
watch page so now let's go back to my
video and let's see what my watch my
watch page numbers are 1.8%
bear in mind average 26%
a really good video on the watch page is
like 50% 1.8% nobody's nobody's seeing
it YouTube just refuses to show it and
so that's when I realized that my video
had been rated in because when when
people are talking about the M rating
what that means is that imagine
YouTube's thinking of who to show stuff
to
when something's rated M it means they
don't want to show it to somebody who
doesn't want to see it and so YouTube's
really hesitant to show rated M videos
on the watch page on pages where people
aren't expecting to see mature content
and so that's how I really oh my that's
why the video is doing so bad it they
got rated M and so YouTube's just
suppressing the ever-living hell out of
it okay so I'm at the point of this is
not what was me it's not pour me pour me
pour me the point of this is that number
one getting rated M really matters to
your videos success I mean that was in
terms of metrics my best video think
ever I haven't checked every video but
that's like my best video ever or at
least as good as it gets so I've made my
best content ever and I get some of the
worst views I've ever gotten so that's
like a take away I mean you know don't
get rated in but now I want to talk
about what that means for the platform
though right like this that doesn't just
impact me obviously a lot of other
creators are going through a lot worse
than I am
on this front let's let's take a step
back and think about what this is
effectively done creators like me have
no way of knowing what content will get
them rated in we we have no clue YouTube
doesn't allow us that insight and we
don't know when we're rated in except by
inferring it because our best video ever
does so poorly and so what does that do
to creators well it makes us really
conservative because I hate to be this
way because in on the one hand I just
believe in quality you know whatever
whatever but on the other hand I make
things to be seen and if they can't be
seen I don't see the point in putting a
month's effort into it and so if you ask
me you know are you gonna make another
vaping video again it was so important
topic I really believe it could affect
millions of lives
no no I I won't I can't I cannot write
because not only was it demonetized
I also had a sponsor on that video this
is just like a fun inside YouTube thing
and my spot my sponsored video didn't
hit its numbers right like you have to
promise how many views is gonna get
whatever and my sponsor video didn't hit
his numbers not because of what I did
but because of what YouTube did so not
only is YouTube not paying me they're
affecting the relationship I have with
these other people that are paying me
and so I cannot afford that
as someone who's supporting himself with
YouTube for that to happen again and so
not only will I might not make fete a
vaping video which is an important
conversation to have by the way also I
don't think I'll be taking on edgy
content in general like why would I why
would I try to and again I don't mean
edgy in the sense of like needlessly
edgy I mean important like a topic of
suicide that's really important
probably sensitive probably going to get
rid of them topics of opioid addiction
that's a video I wanted to do really
thinking about you know scanning that
video if it gets rated in I'm screwed I
have to like and gamble the dice and I
have no way of knowing whether it's
going to be approved through YouTube's
little system or not and so so this has
a real impact on not just the work that
I do but I know it affects other people
too when they have their videos that
don't do so well they realize oh well
people must not be interested in it and
it's maybe not that people aren't
interested it's at YouTube refuses to
show it and so the conversation is just
killed because the useful commentators
who could maybe spend time on it because
they're getting paid to spend time on
the topic now can will not get paid so
on it so they won't make a video on it
so no one's watching it and no one's
watching it anyway because YouTube's not
recommending it and so the important
conversation that should have been had
cannot be had because of this MTAC and I
want to summarize this talk with a very
interesting idea and I think Mike
channel is an interesting case study
that getting rated M on YouTube affects
more than just you're younger than 18
audience because I think that's what a
lot of people think oh well of course we
don't want drug taking you know shown to
kids whatever like we don't want
sensitive content before they're ready
okay I get that and I'm fine with that
but getting rated em affects a lot more
than your young audience and the reason
I know this is that I don't have a very
young audience right so let's go to
lifetime analytics and we're gonna go to
who's watching my view videos because as
you'll see it's not young people
thirteen to seventeen year olds 6.2%
around five percent of my views are
coming from the people who ideally
shouldn't be watching him rated content
everybody else everybody else is older
than that and should be completely fine
with watching M rated content so here's
the golden question why is a channel who
should in theory be the perfect
candidate for a mature rating because my
audience is mature right so it shouldn't
really affect me why is my video getting
affected so much why are my views
getting throttled so much as I said most
of my other videos with these kind of
analytics have gotten 500,000 to a
million views and of course also we have
the evidence of it just not being shown
on the watch page so why is that right
like my target demographic the people
who YouTube is always showing my videos
to are over 18 it's like 95 percent are
over 18 so there's something going on
with whatever method YouTube is using -
soft block videos that are like have
sensitive content in them where they're
not even going out to your mature
audience and that's what's weird that's
what I really have a problem with not
when YouTube doesn't show what they
determined to be a mature video about a
video essay about vaping I don't know
why that's mature but anyway excluding
that as a problem you know I have a
mature audience why is it my mature
audience seeing my mature piece of
content it doesn't make any sense and
this needs to be addressed like now
mature connick creators are some of the
backbone of your plat
and this this is severely affecting not
just the views that of maybe audiences
they shouldn't be shown to but views of
audiences they should be shown to and
that want to see their content so please
fix this YouTube if you're listening
knock-knock-knock
fix this problem change the way you show
mature qanats show it to the people who
want to see it please
it's killing my ability to make
interesting videos about content that is
controversial and it's killing other
creators ability to do the same so yeah
I just wanted to talk about my
experience talk about how you can know
if you're rated in them and and just get
this sort of out to the community
hopefully somebody can you know I don't
know we can just continue the
conversation there's not a really happy
way to end this because the problems
don't seem to be solved very fast that
YouTube and it's hard to get noticed so
yeah I'm just gonna end it